wie heißt es nichts muss e10 und sollen
wir mal die zutaten zeigen hören
da das ist ganz normaler naturjoghurt da
brauchen wir fünf esslöffel genauso
viele 5 und dann brauchen wir zwei
orangen ja die haben wir dann brauchen
wir 150 milliliter wasser und wir
brauchen rote beete uhr rote beete und
zwar 175 gramm und die sind schon
vorgekocht die sind aus dem glas die
kann aber auch selbst vorkochen und
daraus machen wir einen ganz gesunden
und leckeren
jetzt zeig mal was wir jetzt an werkzeug
brauchen was ist das da was du in der
hand hast du brauchen wir auch und wir
brauchen zuerst müssen wir mal die
orangen schälen
und jetzt kannst du dir ganzen orangen
da oben reinschmeißen ja auch die
angeknabberte macht nix draus nicht
auseinander machen
und wer keine orangen da hat er nimmt
einfach orangensaft super und stark
kommt jetzt auch die rote beete mit dazu
das wasser kommt da auch rein und praxis
macht nichts und jetzt noch fünf
esslöffel joghurt
jetzt kommt der deckel drauf und da
machen wir auf stufe sechs okay
fertig ja es ist ja ok warte ich gehe
raus rein schütte schmeckt gut wachsen
auch guten appetit und tschüss
bist du nicht den kindern tschüss sagen
das sind aber ganz traurig dieser ist
jetzt nicht mehr von euch verabschieden
deswegen berichtet ganz schnell
vielleicht noch ganz kurz zu dem rezept
das rezept habe ich aus diesem hoch
säfte und shakes das habe ich mir
irgendwann mal gekauft und da gibt es
eben eine rubrik gesunde vitamine drinks
und deswegen habe ich mit diesen rote
beete und orangen smoothie ausgesucht
weil rote beete ezb hat vor säure und
vitamin c und eben in kombination mit
der orange und den vitaminen kick ist
ich würde empfehlen schenkt man nach zu
machen diesen smoothie wer nicht gerne
mit stückchen ist sollte vielleicht auch
frisch gepressten orangensaft
zurückgreifen man nehme ich diese
fruchtstückchen nicht mit drin
dieses fruchtfleisch und ansonsten ist
es schon ganz andere
geschmacklich finden sowie zwischendurch
einfach mal ganz lecker so ein kleiner
zwischen snack und mir schon eingefahren
als wir den smoothie jetzt gemacht haben
ich war ja mal in berlin vor kurzem da
hatte ich euch ja gesagt dass ich vor
ifa gehen will
allerdings konnte ich nicht direkt zur
ifa gehen weil das zeigt sich bei mir
nicht gepasst hat weil ich dann die
woche später wieder schule hatte und so
weiter dann habe ich von der aktion von
der firma hay erfahren
die haben nämlich ihre haushaltsgeräte
in eine wohnung gestellt
jeder konnte dann dahin und die
haushaltsgerät testen und dann weiter
die moderatorin enie van de meiklokjes
die waren dort und hast die geräte eben
gezeigt wie die funktionieren und ob sie
ihr gefallen oder nicht
da war ich jetzt deutsch ich habe sie
ganz kleinen videoausschnitt für euch
das so ich habe das ganze etwas gekürzt
ihr wolltet der rat so was sehen
deswegen dachte ich mache ich jetzt hier
weil es ganz gut passt hier noch den
kleinen einen schuh betreiben die emi
hat nämlich immer ganz leckeres muti
deshalb für euch das möchte ich euch
jetzt gleich zeigen
der mixer toll bei den steht mir und
weniger staus als ohne kabel
das heißt theoretisch könntest du ihn
später mit der man sagt da es passiert
nicht länger im könntest du einfach
nehmen
genau vor aber ich bin am ende hat man
schon funktioniert weil dann ist das
ganze schon gekühlte muss sich am 11
dann werden
mit einbringen
man kann das schon mal gemacht dann
waren sie gar nicht zum einfrieren die
lösung schnell erschrecken
zuletzt
und der löffel muss drin stehen könnten
auch den test
steht
beinahe gar noch ein bisschen gründen
eine internetgeschwindigkeit
an
wollen wir jetzt natürlich noch für
einen bewerber fast ein bisschen wie
eins
ich hoffe das video hat euch gefallen
und ihr werdet einen der beiden zu sie
ist mal nachmachen
ich wünsche euch auf jeden fall viel
spaß dabei und bis bald
und das ist meine begleitung und erklärt
wie es geht
technik wissenschaft und philosophischen
kanadischen den abo nicht sofort was
machst du heute